le café en fait dans la boutique saveurs
des comptoirs d'amérique latine
d'afrique ou d'asie mme quinzaine de
grands crus vendus dans ce magasin pour
les journées du café une préparation à
l'eau froide et proposés à la
dégustation
une curiosité apprécié on sent vraiment
la délicatesse des arts on se sent
beaucoup plus léger ici avec les cafés
c'est effectivement c'est une boisson
très désaltérante et on conçoit qu'on
puisse boire ça toute la journée par
grosses chaleurs c'est la première fois
que je bois en fait un café froid c'est
à dire on
c'est pas un café chaud qui a refroidi
froid 5 a fait infuser à froid c'est
complètement c'est une autre de
sensations à l'honneur une variété de
café indonésien de sulawesi les grains
sont d'abord mou lui verser à
l'intérieur d'une cafetière pu refuser
ces journées du café sont organisées par
un regroupement de torréfacteurs
français occasion pour thomas journaux
de faire découvrir les secrets de son
métier fait on utilise pour ça une
machine qui va apporter
des grains en température jusqu'à 200
degrés à l'intérieur du tambour
cette température va être cette montée
va être progressive et on va passer par
différentes phases différentes
techniques étaient vraiment la
torréfaction qui va permettre de
développer toutes ses saveurs et
d'arômes
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition des journées du café
afin d'éveiller nos papilles gustatives